le samedi 16 juillet restera un jour
gravé dans les mémoires de la famille le
bal riche et c'est le jour où
christopher et élodie se sont dit oui à
la mairie et pas devant n'importe qui
puisque c'est leur fils lohan disant eh
merde du conseil des jeunes de langer
qui a marié ses parents oui
[Musique]
l'adjointe à la
phrase principal on prépare les pour ma
demande et
propose
déjà qu'elodie la maman a la larme
facile alors voir son enfant prononcé la
fameuse question rituelle voulez vous
prendre pour époux christopher le bal
ici présent ça continue de remuer la
mère du mini mère très émue forcément
parce qu'on n'était pas du tout au
courant en fait on savait vraiment pas
pour nous il serait juste présent en
fait il serait juste voilà à côté de mes
fils de l'autre côté de la table avec sa
petite écharpe bleu blanc rouge du
conseil municipal on pensait pas du tout
qu'il allait prendre la parole et sur
des passages vraiment très et très
solennelle en fait ce qu'il a demandé à
monsieur le ballet acceptez vous de
prendre pour épouse et inversement moi
en me demandant si je voulais prendre
pour épouse marie donc ça a été très des
moments très forts en fait
le mandat de lohan en tant que maire du
conseil des jeunes de langeais prend fin
à la rentrée de septembre
nul doute que le garçon qui va rentrer
en 6e gardera ce moment familial comme
un souvenir inoubliable